Ich habe einen Vorschlag. Da wir uns ja mit Intrusion Detection und Incident Response auseinandersetzen wollen, könnten wir uns ja mit dem Detection-Teil eher auseinandersetzen.
Du musst vor allem in deinem Mikrofon sprechen.
Da ist doch ein Mikrofon hier. Aber jeder Incident Response-Teil läuft eben nicht nach einem fertigen Ablauf. Du hast bei jedem Angriff und bei jeder betroffenen Organisation andere Schutzziele, andere Prioritäten. Das macht ja den Job auch so interessant.
Es ist ja ähnlich wie eine Partie Schach. Dein Gegner wählt immer andere Züge.
Aber ich würde gerne einmal ein konkretes Beispiel sagen. Es ist dann klar, dass nicht alles so abläuft. Aber einmal was Konkretes. Dann können wir davon gerne wieder hoch abstrehen. Wolpertule, hattest du gerade dir etwas ausgedacht?
Ein nicht ganz unrealistisches Beispiel ist, man hat irgendwo eine Störung und will die beheben. Und die geht irgendwie nicht weg. Dann holt man sich beispielsweise den Hersteller, der guckt sich das auch an, tauscht die Hardware. Die Störung tritt erneut auf. Und dann beginnt man halt mit Bordmilden zu gucken, was ist da? Und dann findet jemand auf seinem Windows-System eine Software, die angeblich zu Novell gehört. Und dann sagen alle auf einmal, Moment mal, wir haben gar kein Novell, was soll das werden, wenn es fertig ist? Dann macht jemand genau das, was man nicht tun sollte, lädt das zu Virus Total hoch und da sagt dann ein Viren-Scanner, okay, das ist böse.
Warum sollte man das nicht tun?
Weil Virus Total praktisch öffentlich ist. Wenn du eine Utility da hoch lädst, das ein Täter für dich gebaut hat, dann kann der Täter einfach bei Virus Total schön prüfen, ob du ihn gefunden hast.
Virus Total ist so ein Ding, da lädt man eine Datei hoch und dann guckt er bei verschiedenen Viren-Scanner-Maschinen, was die dazu sagen. Aber die Ergebnisse werden auch gepostet?
Die Ergebnisse sind eigentlich praktisch für jeden öffentlich. Das ist ja mehr oder weniger, das ist eigentlich genau der Sinn der Übung. Das ist nicht privat. Also auch wenn ich beispielsweise eine komische Datei per Mail kriege und ich lade da hoch und das war das Bewerbungsschreiben von jemandem, dann liegt da das Bewerbungsschreiben von jemandem auf Virus Total rum. Genau und jetzt als normaler Privatunwender sehe ich jetzt nur, okay, da gibt es irgendwie eine Datei, die heißt halt xyz.docx und da ist kein Virus drin. Aber es gibt eben auch noch professionelle Zugänge eben für Malwärner-Listen, für Incident Responder, die kosten halt eine Menge Geld. Aber da kommt man dann im Prinzip auch an den Content. Also da kommt man dann anhand von Signaturen. Also ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ich möchte mal die Datei sowieso haben. Also man kann nach Kriterien suchen, aber man kann auch nach Signaturen suchen. Und gezielt natürlich auch nach Daten, die hochgeladen wurden, die vielleicht auch gar keine hatten. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendeine Signatur für irgendeine ganz spezifische Malware hab, die vielleicht jetzt nicht so allgemein bekannt ist und wo vielleicht so in den normalen AV-Signaturen gar nichts mehr drin ist, dann könnte ich trotzdem Hits bekommen, wenn eben jemand eine verdächtige Datei auf Virus-Total hochlädt und im Worst Case kriegt ein Analyst dann natürlich die Konfig raus. Also sieht dann, okay, da ist irgendwie ein Kampagnencode drin oder da ist irgendwie irgendwelche Domänen oder irgendwelche... Kampagnencode-Domänen sind, also Täter sind oft sehr beschäftigt und müssen viele Ziele angreifen, dann wissen sie manchmal nicht mehr, wem habe ich welche Malware gegeben. Deswegen schreiben sie einen Schlüssel in die Malware, dann ist es noch einiger und dann ist der Schlüssel eventuell der Name vom Opfer.
Die Kundennummer sozusagen. Aber zurück zum, ich entdecke auf meinem System eine Software von Novell, die da eigentlich gar nicht ist.
Genau, und dann merkt man, dass es irgendwie unlogisch und dann sagt jemand, hey, das ist doch hier ein Server, auf dem surft niemand, da kann sich niemand eine Malware einfangen. Und dann ist natürlich klar, die ist da nicht von außen drauf gekommen. Jemand kam von innen vom Netz und hat mir da eine Malware hingelegt. Und dann weiß ich natürlich, okay, wenn sich jemand in meinem Netz frei bewegen kann und mir da Tools installieren kann, dann ist eben offensichtlich mein Netzwerk eben kompromittiert. Und dann, klar, heutzutage ist man da natürlich weitaus verständnisvoll und sagt, okay, wenn ich nicht rausfinde, wie er da reinkommt, dann bringt es nichts, wenn ich diesen einen Server neu installiere, weil dann kommt er eben im Seiferts-Fall einfach wieder. Und ich muss wahrscheinlich mehr Sachen machen als nur hier so ein an ein, zwei Schräubchen drehen, weil ich weiß ja auch nicht, wie lange derjenige drin ist. Im Zweifelsfall sehe ich Zeitstempel und sehe, oh Gott, die Datei, die ist schon ein Jahr alt. Dann ist mir natürlich klar, okay, es bringt wahrscheinlich nichts, wenn ich mir hier zwei Systeme angucke und gucke, wo die Datei ist, und die lösche ich dann. Sondern da ist jemand da, der kennt ja meine Infrastruktur schon und der wird dann vielleicht auch andere Tricks drauf haben. Und genau in dem Punkt ist dann oft der Punkt da, wo jemand sagt, okay, jetzt hole ich mir da zusätzliche Leute rein. Nicht nur unbedingt, um sich um das Incident zu kümmern, sondern jemand sagt, hey, ich muss ja das Netz noch reparieren. Das heißt, ich brauche mehr Leistung als sonst. Da brauche ich dann vielleicht auch einfach Leute, die wirklich die allgemeinen Tätigkeiten machen, die man braucht, um so ein Netzwerk zu flicken.
Wenn man sowas entdeckt hat, ist das dann schon das Ziel, das möglichst schnell wegzumachen oder kann auch ein Teil sein, man beobachtet, was das macht und vielleicht auch sogar, wo das hingeht und forscht mal ein bisschen nach, was da passiert.
Das kommt auf die Lage an. Nimm mal an, man hat irgendwie jemand, der sitzt in einem kleinen Außenbüro, der hat da einen PC, hat gesagt, hat eine komische E-Mail gekriegt und schickt die weiter, dass sich die jemand anguckt. Und er sagt dann, sorry Leute, ich hab drauf geklickt. Und dann merkt man, okay, das ist irgendeine Spionage-Software. Wenn man jetzt weiß, der Kollege, der war gerade nicht im VPN, dann ruft man ihn natürlich an, hier, mach deinen Rechner aus. Und dann ist ja das sozusagen, ist erst mal das Problem gelöst, weil man weiß, das ist isoliert. Wenn man noch nicht weiß, wo der oder das überall gewesen sein kann, dann muss ich natürlich erst mal finden, okay, wo kommt es überall her, wohin hat es sich überall verbreitet, dann muss man erst, also das moderne Begriff, dann eben die Sichtbarkeit schaffen. Also ich muss wissen, wo sich die Täter überall bewegen.
Genau, was ich aber meinte ist, wenn ich dann weiß, also in meinem Netzwerk, was ich jetzt gerade betreue, da weiß ich jetzt, wo das überall sitzt, ist dann noch von Interesse zu verfolgen, wo der zum Beispiel Daten hinsendet und da Nachfragen anzustellen ist, dann ist eure Aufgabe eigentlich nur, okay, ich mach jetzt sozusagen, ich finde, also wenn ich gefunden habe, wo es über ist, dann mach ich das ganz.
Also die Information, was der Täter eigentlich will, die ist also wirklich ihr Gewicht in Gold wert, weil wenn du ein großes Netz hast, ab einer gewissen Größe sagt man heute, okay, da sind immer irgendwo Probleme. Also so wie man in Berlin nicht sagen kann, wir können hier irgendwann mal dafür sorgen, dass es keinen Taschendiebstahl mehr gibt, das geht nicht. Und dann dir gegenüber offenbart ja der Täter, was er will und dann weißt du, aha, Moment mal, vielleicht sind das Informationen, die kann ich irgendwie abschotten. Die sind nur begrenzt, Personen nutzen die, die sind auf begrenzt System und dann hat der Täter mir mehr oder weniger wirklich gesagt, genau das will ich und dann weiß ich, okay, für die Daten, für die investiere ich am meisten, weil die sind ihm am meisten wert und dann kann ich sozusagen im Zweifelsfall, wenn ich richtig Glück habe und er will nur was Bestimmtes, dann kann ich ihn ausheben, in dem ich sage, okay, ich entziehe ihm die Daten, ich ziehe die sozusagen aus dem jetzt kompromittierten, also aus dem verseuchten Netz raus, tue die in einen eigenen Bereich oder ich weiß sogar, vielleicht kann ich die Daten für eine Weile unzugänglich machen, weil die nicht immer gebraucht werden und dann habe ich sein Interesse unterlaufen. Das ist sozusagen das absolute Optimum. Es kann immer sein, dass das eine Weile dauert, weil die Täter wissen das und die probieren natürlich eine ganze Reihe von Strategien anzuwenden, um genau so etwas zu vermeiden, zum Beispiel indem sie sich einfach sehr aggressiv im Netz verbreiten. Wenn ich sie dann finde, sie sind hier, sie sind da, sie sind dort, dann kenne ich ja immer noch nicht das Interesse. Ich weiß nur, die wollen sich bei mir festsetzen und die meisten Täter, wenn sie nicht auf den Kopf gefallen sind, dann werden die auch sehr vorsichtig bei so was sein. Das ist ja ihr Job, ihr Job ist ja Daten zu stehlen. Die sollen nicht Trojaner machen, wo wir alle sagen, wow, ist der cool, der Trojaner, der ist so geil.
Also es geht ja eher darum, möglichst einfach Informationen zu beschaffen und nicht mit einem hohen Aufwand aus Angreifversicht.
Also was mich am meisten beeindruckt, das sind die einfachen Tricks, die trotzdem funktionieren. Also wenn Täter mit ganz wenig Aufwand sozusagen jemanden aufs Kreuz legen, wo man dann sagt, hey, das ist eigentlich schon clever, weil das ist ja kosteneffizient.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob man das Hacking becken nennen soll, aber quasi nachforschen, wohin die Softwaredaten sendet und dann sozusagen versuchen, dem irgendwie auch eins oder zwei zu schieben, das ist nicht so von Interesse.
Das Problem ist, das ist extrem Zeit- und Ressourcenintensiv und auch, wie man schön sagen würde, rechtlich problematisch. Es besteht die Gefahr, wenn ich da zu viel mache, dann lasse ich mich ja von der Hauptaufgabe ablenken, nämlich das muss ja irgendwann geflickt werden und das soll ja auch irgendwann aufhören. Das ist also relativ diffizil und wie gesagt, es besteht dann die Gefahr, dass ich mich auf einen Aspekt des Problems total überfokussiere und dann beispielsweise vergesse, dass ich dann noch ein ganzes Netz habe, was ja irgendwie es braucht, eine gewisse Robustheit, damit es beim nächsten Mal nicht mehr passiert. Und das andere Problem ist, dass natürlich, es gibt ja da draußen, da kann man ja Berichte lesen, da gibt es ja schon, glaube ich, das Älteste, ne, das Neueste war, dass die das Amerikaner geschrieben haben, dass sie den Fall zurückgehackt haben. Das Problem ist, die Täter erwarten so was. Das heißt also, es besteht natürlich die Gefahr, dass man sie genau dann mit der Nase drauf stört, ich habe eure Tricks gefunden, ich weiß, wo ihr seid. Und was ein professioneller Täter macht, der zieht sich dann natürlich sofort zurück. Dann wartet er, bis das Drama vorbei ist, bis alle sozusagen sagen, wir haben jetzt keinen Bock mehr, das war so anstrengend. Und dann geht das Ganze wieder von vorne los.
Okay, vielen Dank, Fanny, für das konkrete Beispiel. Jetzt verstehe ich auch lange die Komplexität an dem Job. Also zu gucken, wo ein Programm läuft, das kann man sozusagen, wenn es ein einfaches Programm ist, relativ einfach, wenn man weiß, wie ein Betriebssystem funktioniert. Aber das gibt es dann wahrscheinlich in verschiedenen Abstufungen und wie man das versteckt und in verschiedenen Komplexitätsgraden. Dann können auch noch andere Dinge passieren. Jetzt zu dem, was Linus am Anfang der halben Stunde gesagt hat, Intrusion Detection ist sozusagen ein Werkzeugkasten. Was braucht man da alles? Was muss man alles können?
Na ja, du hast ja, wenn ich mir jetzt deinen Computer so anschaue, da ist diese Software drauf und du gehst jetzt irgendwie davon aus, dass der ordnungsgemäß funktioniert.
Meistens.
Wenn der jetzt irgendwie Probleme haben würde, was würdest du denn gerne als Informationen über diesen Computer haben? Wenn du sagst, du möchtest möglichst früh wissen, dass er das Ziel, dass der gehackt wurde. Also du möchtest, dein Ziel ist ja, du möchtest das früh wissen, damit du früh reagieren kannst, damit du Schaden abwenden kannst. Was würdest du denn wissen wollen über deinen Computer? Wenn ich sage, was wäre der einfachste Indikator für dich, für dein Risiko?
Das Lustige ist, da entscheide ich tatsächlich sozusagen häufig, weil man kann sich ja, also ich kann mir als einfacher User angucken, welche Prozesse in meinem Computer laufen und welcher Prozess Daten sendet.
Sagt dir aber nichts.
Genau, dann googelt man das und dann so, ja, das ist möglicher. Dann findet man sozusagen 30 andere Anfragen, wo auch Leute, das ist sozusagen gesucht haben, wenn niemand weiß, was es ist.
Würde es dich zum Beispiel weiterbringen, würde es dich weiterbringen, den Computer, wenn du den kaufst, guckst du dir an, welche Prozesse laufen da drauf und jedes Mal, wenn du irgendwie ein neues Programm installiert hast und der startet, guckst du dir das wieder an und führst darüber Buch. Was führt dieser Computer aus? Was gibt er mir auf seinen Diagnosetools aus, wenn, was weiß ich hier, was ist das für eine freie Software? Ableton Live. Was ist, wenn da Ableton Live drauf läuft und was ist, wenn da irgendwas anderes drauf läuft?
Das wäre meine Idee davon. Ich schreibe mir alle Prozesse auf, die es gibt und auch die, die Daten senden dürfen und empfangen dürfen.
Genau, dass du zum Beispiel sagst, was passiert, wenn hier jemand Daten rausschicken möchte. Du willst ja einfache, niedrigschwellige Indikatoren. Du könntest ja auch sagen, ich achte mal darauf, wie viel Internet-Traffic mein Computer so macht. Ich lade ja von mir aus den ganzen Tagen nur Chaos-Radien hoch. Insofern dürfte der eigentlich relativ wenig aus dem Internet laden, weil ich ja keine Updates mache oder vielleicht ist er auch umgekehrt. Und du sagst, der sollte eigentlich relativ wenig Traffic nach innen haben. Ich surfe nicht in Russland. Und so baust du dir eigentlich möglichst vielleicht ein bisschen Sichtbarkeit darüber, was dieser Computer macht.
Und jetzt hast du aber dieses Problem mal 1000. Das Problem mal 1000 ist ja dann wahrscheinlich auch eher eine Ressourcenfrage. Es gibt sozusagen eine gute Vorbereitung. Man kann Systeme gut vorbereiten, indem man genau so was macht. Du möchtest sowas halt automatisiert haben und an einer zentralen Stelle. Und das ist halt der wichtige Punkt, dass die Sachen an einer zentralen Stelle auflaufen und auch genügend Ressourcen da sind, wenn es zur Alarmierung kommt. Weil du kannst auch ein Benachrichtigungssystem dran knüpfen. Das heißt, wenn gewisse Unregelmäßigkeiten auftauchen, dass du auf einmal plötzlich einen relativ hohen Download hast.
Obwohl du eigentlich sonst nur Upload hast.
Weil du lädst ja nur Chaos-Radio Folgen hoch, aber lädst halt sonst nicht aus dem Netz runter.
Und dann haben wir ja schon eine Anomalie, die auftritt. Und dass du bei so einer Anomalie und bei allen anderen halt auch eine automatische Benachrichtigung vom System bekommst.
Und dann wirst du darauf schon aufmerksam. Und dann ist wieder eine Ressourcenfrage, ob du alle Unregelmäßigkeiten, die auftreten, tatsächlich auch in einer gewissen Zeitspanne bearbeiten kannst und den ganzen nachgehen kannst. Ich frage mich, warum gibt es das nicht für normale Computer?
Na ja, gibt's ja.
Was?
Wieso wurde ich nicht informiert?
Du würdest vielleicht sowas wie, was würde man nehmen? Also, Sort oder so.
Was für ein Ding?
Das Problem bei diesen ganzen Lösungen, also generisch gesprochen, ohne Brandnamen zu nennen, ist immer dieses Baselining. Also ich hab jetzt, wenn ich eine Firma hab, wo sich irgendwie alle Computer ein bisschen ähnlich verhalten, das sind jetzt alles, weiß ich nicht, Mailserver, Webserver, was auch immer, die haben irgendwo einen Pattern, was die immer machen und die haben bestimmte Dinge, die machen die nie. Und ich will jetzt bei einem vernünftigen Intrusion Detection System erstmal irgendwie schauen oder generell, also jetzt nicht nur die Software, sondern mein Gesamt-Setup, mein Intrusion Detection Setup, würde ich dann erstmal bei allen vorhandenen Komponenten, wo ich irgendwie Daten herbekomme, dann gucken, okay, wie ist meine Baseline, was ist überhaupt normal? Und wird dann von da aus loslaufen und diese Abweichung dann alarmieren lassen. Bei so einem normalen, ich sag mal General Purpose End-User Laptop, da ist viel mehr Varianz drin, was der so tut den ganzen Tag. Da ist das dann typischerweise auch in den Produkten so, dass ich dann nicht mehr nur darauf verlassen werde, dass jetzt irgendwie nur geguckt wird, wo surfe ich jetzt hin oder was habe ich in meinem Windows-Log stehen, sondern dass das eine Kombination dann ist, irgendwie mit Virenscannern, signaturbasierten, emulierten. Also, dass dann, was meine Binaries machen, die ich jetzt vielleicht nicht kenne, das wird dann so nachgestellt, geht dann auch schon mal kaputt, wie Tavis schon mal merkt. Und da wird dann eben Anomalie Detection gemacht. Dann wird noch mal geschaut, okay, wenn ich da sitze bei manchen Produkten in einer Sandbox, du machst das irgendwie ein komisches Funkt, also ist es dann immer eine Kombination von ganz vielen Technologien.
Du musst dir das so vorstellen. Du hast von mir ein Virenscanner auf dem Rechner. Jetzt geht dir das Unternehmen oder die Organisation hin und sagt, wir bauen aber auch noch mal ein Virenscanner auf den Mail-Server. Wir haben außerdem einen Web-Server, der irgendwas macht. Vor dem Web-Server haben wir eine Web Application Firewall. Dazu haben wir sowieso eine Firewall, auch in unserem System. All diese Systeme kommen von unterschiedlichen Herstellern und sind alle mit viel Geld bezahlt worden. Weil du ja, also der Prozess ist ganz klar von der Customer Experience, du kaufst dir so ein Ding und es ist eigentlich völlig egal, welches Security Appliance oder Produkt das ist. Die machen danach erst mal einen riesen Radau, um dir die ganze Zeit zu sagen, ich bin da, ich bin mein Geld wert. Also sowas wie, hier hat gerade ein Port Scan stattgefunden. Also hier hat jemand Verbindungen auf verschiedenen Ports gemacht, versucht. Das ist ein gescheiterter Angriff oder ein Angriffsversuch oder ein Port Enumeration oder was auch immer. Und jetzt hast du davon, ich glaube, wenn du so irgendwie Best Practice Bücher anschaust, dann hast du für jetzt eine größere Organisation sowas wie 32 dieser Dinge, also Firewall, Web Application, Firewall, irgendein Scheiß. Ich kenne die Liste selber nicht auswendig. Das heißt, du hast diese teilweise zentrale Systeme, teilweise aber auch verteilte Systeme. Und jetzt möchtest du irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass du überhaupt erst mal einen Überblick darüber beschaffst. Also sagst du denen, die sollen alle ihre Information an eine zentrale Stelle liefern. Dein Monitoring System. Und da prasseln dann irgendwie, also es ist echt im Normalbetrieb, wo du wirklich sagst, okay, wahrscheinlich geht hier gerade nichts schief, prasseln da trotzdem halt Unmengen an Alerts. Irgendwie viele Tausende bis hunderttausend oder zehntausende rein.
Also bei den Kollegen, die die Systeme betreuen, leuchtet halt die Lampe die ganze Zeit rot. Und die sind erst mal primär damit beschäftigt, entsprechend zu filtern, was ist kritisch, was ist unkritisch.
Also was ist gewollt und was ist ungewollt. Und dann bist du dabei zu sagen, okay vieles was jetzt hier gerade passiert ist, ist totaler Unsinn und dann fängst du an die Sachen wegzudefinieren. Zu sagen, okay ich möchte mich interessiert nicht, wenn ein Portscan stattfindet. Aber wenn ein Portscan stattfindet, dann interessiert mich alles, was die IP danach noch macht. Also die einfache Regel, die ich immer so als Erläuterung nehme, dich interessiert nicht, dass tausendmal versucht wurde, sich bei deinem System einzuloggen. Aber wenn es beim tausend und ersten mal passiert und funktioniert und der Login klappt, dann möchtest du, dass irgendwie so eine rote Lampe angeht und einen Alarm erört. Und diese Regeln schreibst du dir in einem Team möglichst selber. du willst erst mal dein Monitoring-System zum Schweigen bringen. Und dann machst du dir Gedanken darüber, was möchte ich denn hier überhaupt noch hören? Das sind dann individuelle Korrelationsregeln. Das ist Vorarbeit. Die aber, weil dieses Monitoring-System, nur weil es dir nicht sagt, die Support-Scan hat stattgefunden, weil es da nicht irgendwie die gelb oder rot, oder welche Farbe auch immer, die sich da ausdenken, tief lila oder so. Nur weil es diese Informationen dir nicht mehr anzeigt auf Anhieb, heißt das nicht, dass sie nicht trotzdem da drin ist. Das heißt, du hast einerseits ein kluges Monitoring und dann das, was man so Drill-Down nennt. Dass du dann eben sagst, ach okay, hier ist eine IP-Adresse, die interessiert mich. Und dann sagt dir die sofort, okay, die ist in diesem Land vermutlich lokalisiert. Die hat zuletzt die Webseite besucht und dann im Online-Shop fünfmal eine falsche Kreditkartennummer eingegeben. Beim sechsten Mal hat es geklappt oder solche Scherze, dass du dann halt wirklich die ganzen Informationen, die du da zentral sammelst, nachher möglichst schön wieder dir anschauen kannst. Weil was du nicht vergessen darfst, ist so eine große Organisationsinfrastruktur mit den ganzen Desktop-Rechnern, mit den ganzen Servern, mit den Tausenden von Services, die da irgendwo stattfinden. Die versteht einfach kaum noch jemand. Und diesen Überblick als Einzelperson wieder hinzukriegen, dabei helfen dir solche Monitoring-Geschichten.
Ich nehme den aber auch, das ist nur so ein kleiner Ranschlenker, Systeme, die eine gute Intuition-Detekte haben, sind nicht unbedingt durch Datensparsamkeit ausgezeichnet.
Das würde ich sagen auch jetzt eher nicht, aber es hängt schon, also es gibt bestimmte Merkmale, die klug sind zu erheben, die jetzt nicht direkt irgendwie sensitiv gegenüber dem Benutzer, der vielleicht ein System sitzt, aber die eben Sinn machen, um Angreifer zu erkennen. Und da jetzt irgendwie solche Datenpunkte dann zu definieren, und zu sagen, okay, das erhebe ich jetzt und das nicht. Das ist dann eben Aufgabe von einem guten Analysten, der dann eben dieses System mit einrichtet. Und natürlich auch teilweise abhängig von meinen Produkten, die ich dann im Endeffekt benutze. Also ich kann jetzt hingehen und kann halt irgendwie Sysmon oder sowas, also ein freies Microsoft-Tool aus der Sysinternal-Suite benutzen, um irgendwie das Logging hochzudrehen und da bestimmte Events zu definieren, die ich mir angucken will. Oder ich kann jetzt auch irgendwie so ein, irgendwas Enterprise-Produkt kaufen, was noch viel mehr tut. Und irgendwie, also jetzt nicht im Sinne von besser mehr, aber anders mehr. Und irgendwie jetzt dann noch, weiß ich nicht, irgendwelche Endpoints-Scanner ihren Geschichten macht und mir dann sowohl meine Info-Notifications macht. Also irgendwie so, da ist was passiert. Also nicht unbedingt, dass es jetzt evil und dann on top vielleicht noch so, okay, ich habe jetzt irgendeine Malwege gefunden.
Aber das ist sozusagen, das ist die Vorbereitung eigentlich. Also eigentlich das sozusagen, wenn dieses Regelset, was du beschrieben hast sozusagen, wenn das da ist, dann dann läuft das System erst mal. Und das heißt, man darf aber nicht vergessen, dass Regeln auch immer nachgeschärft werden müssen.
Also wann immer Veränderungen im Netzwerk stattfinden.
Lass mich mal bitte den Gedanken zuführen. Weil es gibt dieses Regelsystem und ja, das muss auch so sagen, nachgearbeitet werden, aber das ist ja nicht sozusagen, es gibt ja dann den Punkt, wo man die incident responder wiederholt. Weil man glaubt, also dann hat er dieses Regelwerk dann angeschlagen und hat gesagt, so jetzt ist aber wirklich was komisch.
Ja, dann hat ein Regelwerk auch fast schon versagt.
Also das System heißt, du baust deine eigene incident response Kapazitäten auf. Du willst ja als Organisation eigentlich in der Lage sein, dass die meisten Sachen gar nicht das sind, was wir als incident bezeichnen. Das heißt, du baust dir mit so einem Monitoring auf, dann passieren zum Beispiel so Sachen wie keine Ahnung.
Aber das heißt, wenn ihr kommt, dann hat jemand nicht das gebaut, was du gerade erklärt hast.
Oder nur unverständlich. Ja doch, der hat das vielleicht gebaut, er war einfach nur ein besserer Angreifer.
Gut, das war eben was, was Volper Tu auch ganz am Anfang gesagt hat. Man will natürlich bestehende Struktur nutzen. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo bei einem Kunden bin und der hat sich jetzt schon ein super tolles Syslog Collection System in irgendeiner Form gebaut, dann wird man das natürlich benutzen. Also dann wird man natürlich hingehend darauf aufbauen, vielleicht schauen, dass es da irgendwie eine sinnvolle Abdeckung von vielleicht Infrastruktur, die eventuell vergessen wurde oder aus irgendwelchen budgetären Gründen noch nicht eben wandelt wurde. Das wird man dann eben nachziehen und wird dann eben gucken, dass man zumindest die Bereiche, wo man meint, die interessant sind, dass die da mit drin sind, wird da drin dann eben nach Anomalien suchen. Also man arbeitet natürlich allein aus der Logik erst mal mit dem, was da ist. Und typischerweise, wenn jemand ein so gutes Monitoring hat, dass er den Angriff sehr gut selber eingrenzt, dann kann er das auch beheben. Dann kann er sagen, hier diese vier oder fünf Kleins, die hat es erwischt, da hat jemand eine Nachricht geschickt, eine Mail und diese fünf Leute haben drauf geklickt. Ich habe das rechtzeitig gesehen. Ich ziehe die Rechner aus dem Verkehr. Alles gut. Und vielleicht mache ich dann noch ein paar nachgelagerte Analysen, um einfach sicher zu sein, dass ich, was dieser Angreifer macht, noch mal kommt. Wenn jetzt irgendwelche Lücken drin sind, dass jemand sagt, ich habe hier was auf meinem Server gefunden. Also die ideal Standard-Anomalie ist wirklich, ich habe ein Antivirus-Alert auf einem Server im Netz, wo ich davon ausgehe, dass jemand das von innen gepusht haben muss. Und dann sind in dem Monitoring ja irgendwelche Lücken offensichtlich. Das heißt, ich habe die Bewegung dorthin nicht gesehen. Und dann guckt man, wie gleicht man die aus. Und wenn dann jemand sagt, mein Problem ist, ich würde ja gerne mehr Lock-Quellen anschließen, aber wie Linus gesagt hat, ich kriege so viele Events, die Büchse, die wir da haben, die kommt nicht hinterher. Dann muss man natürlich sagen, okay, dann brauchen wir Infrastruktur arbeiten und müssen gucken, dass das Gerät, was da vor Ort ist, einfach mehr Events verarbeiten kann. Oder wenn jemand sagt, ich habe mich da verhauen, ich habe eine Technologie genommen, mit der bin ich nicht zufrieden, dann sagt man, okay, wir arbeiten mit der bestehenden Technologie so lange wie es geht und gucken, dass man halt nebenher so YOLO-mäßig, würde man wahrscheinlich sagen, was Neues aufbaut.
Ich habe jetzt ein verständliches Problem, und zwar ich hätte, also weil du am Anfang dieses Beispiel gemacht hast, und jetzt sagen wir, wie man so ein System baut, dass man Dinge erkennen kann, dachte ich, dass eine Möglichkeit doch ist, okay, ich habe dieses Intrusion Detection sozusagen Automatisierung aufgebaut, dass es dann auch den Fall geben kann, das System erkennt, hier stimmt etwas nicht, und das kann ich abschalten, aber du hast ja vorhin gesagt, es kann ja immer sein, ich entdecke das etwas Falsches, ich weiß aber nicht, warum das da ist. Ich dachte, das kann auch passieren, dass das Intrusion Detection System sagt, okay, da ist was schief, und ich weiß auch, was schief ist, ich weiß dann aber nicht, wie es da passiert ist.
Das ist dann die typische Aufgabe eben von einem Zert. Typischerweise will man da jetzt nicht jedes Mal, wenn man irgendwas Komisches sieht. Also irgendeine Person muss ja eh davor sitzen.
Nein, ich meine sozusagen, das Intrusion Detection System entdeckt, da läuft was schief, also es gibt diesen Prozess, der Daten irgendwo hinschickt, und ich weiß auch, was da schief läuft und wo das hingeht, was ich nicht will, aber ich weiß aber nicht, wie es da hingekommen ist.
Von welchem Host das gekommen ist?
Welche Sicherheitslücke ausgenutzt wurde oder wie genau passiert das? Das kannst du ja vielleicht auch gar nicht wissen im Vorfeld, weil gegebenenfalls ein Angreifer einen Zero-Day-Exploit genutzt hat, dann wird eine Schwachstelle ausgenutzt, die bis dato nicht bekannt ist. Meine Frage ist ja genauso, gibt es das als Szenario?
Das muss ja noch nicht meine Zero-Day sein, das kann da einfach irgendwas sein, was jetzt irgendwie keine Events auslöst. Also ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht so ein Eternal Blue-Double-Pulser, ich weiß jetzt nicht, da wird wahrscheinlich keine Registry Keys anlegen oder irgendetwas tun, er schreibt halt in Memory irgendwie Zeug, führt das aus und wenn jetzt dem Angreifer nicht irgendwie seine Payload wegcrasht, dann sehe ich auch keine Events. Also selbst wenn ich ein ungepatchtes System hab, wird da kein, also selbst wenn es im Monitoring und sowas ist, dann sehe ich vielleicht andere Anualien, also irgendwie da ist, irgendwie der VESUS ist kaputt und da wurden keine Patches installiert oder sowas, aber ich sehe dann ja nicht unbedingt, dass jetzt da jetzt irgendwie jetzt gerade ein Event erzeugt wird, weil sich da ein Angreifer irgendwie drauf die Kiste aufgemacht hat. Das steht an dem Event leider nicht dran, ob es ein Angreifer war.
Genau, aber ist das dann auch eure Aufgabe auch rauszufinden?
Das ist ja aber echt ein Feature.
Aber ist es dann auch eure Aufgabe zu sagen, das dann rauszufinden?
Genau.
Diesen einen Schritt mehr zu gehen, der das System nicht kann.
Das ist dann halt genau die Handarbeit, also es ist mehr oder weniger immer zu gucken, was kann das bestehende System, was fehlt und dann natürlich aus was auch immer zur Verfügung steht, so viel wie möglich rauszukratzen, um die bestehenden Systeme zu verbessern oder eben wirklich sagen, okay, das ist irgendwie schiefgegangen. Wir haben hier ein Monitoring-System, das bringt die Leistung nicht, die das Opfer sich davon wünscht und dann kann man natürlich sagen, okay, das muss man irgendwie vielleicht anders aufbauen und man kann natürlich dann auch während einem Incident was aufbauen, was total hässlich ist. Das ist dann, dient eben einfach nur wirklich der Gefahrenabwehr und zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt macht man das dann sozusagen in hübsch, weil da soll es ja erst mal nur sozusagen halt mit dem Angreifer, den man da an der Backe hat, eben klarkommen.
Also das war jetzt sehr unterhaltsam, die eineinhalb Stunden, die wir jetzt schon hier sitzen, aber die Hauptmessage, die ich mitgenommen habe, ist, wenn man sich genug vorbereitet, dann braucht man das eigentlich nicht.
Das wäre der, wenn wir gut genug vorbereitet werden, bräuchten wir dich nicht. Natürlich.
Von der du träumst.
Wenn du gut genug vorbereitet bist, brauchst du irgendjemanden nicht. Aber man möchte ja schon irgendwie auch an den Stand kommen, dass man natürlich irgendwie eine eigene Abwehrkraft entwickelt. Und nochmal so eine große Organisation hat stündlich oder minütlich irgendwelche Alerts oder Incidents und das ist nicht immer so, dass dann hier, wie Cevas das gerade schon bemüht hat, die Klärschlammsortierer kommen müssen. Aber die Klärschlammsortierer haben eben echt Ahnung von Klärschlamm.
Ja, aber worauf ich noch was wollte, ist, man kann sich sehr gut vorbereiten und man kann sehr gut Vorsorge darauf treffen, was man machen kann, wenn es mal schief geht. Du musst ja entsprechend auch in deinem Monitoring, wie wir das eingangs schon mal gesagt haben, diese Kritikalität einsortieren bei Sicherheitsvorfällen. Also was ist Low, Medium, High und entsprechend critical, das musst du in deinem Alerting-System auch mit hinterlegen. Ich wiederhole die Frage nochmal, man kann sich sehr gut vorbereiten und dann kann man auch dafür Sorge tragen, dass man gut vorbereitet ist, falls es schief geht.
Ja, im Zweifel selbst. Wenn man jetzt ein super Log-Collection-System und Intrusion-Detection-System, das sind ja auch jetzt alles Werkzeuge, selbst wenn da mal was schief geht, dann bringt es einem immer noch was. Weil wenn dann jetzt die Instant Responder kommen, dann muss man das nicht erst dann teuer bauen, sondern dann kann man das eben direkt benutzen.
Also das Schöne ist ja auch, du hast dann schon gewisse Nachweise in deinem System, wo du nachvollziehen kannst, wie sich Leute bewegt haben, was von A nach B gewandert ist, was man dann halt auswerten muss. Aber das Schöne ist, du hast die Daten, was natürlich fatal ist in so einer Situation.
Du hast gar keine Daten.
Okay, also das heißt, man kann sie so vorbereiten, dass ihr möglichst wenig Arbeit habt, weil alle Vorbereitungen da sind. Und dann kann man sozusagen vielleicht auch für den Ernstfall vorsagen. Das beschreibe ich gleich in der letzten halben Stunde. Vorher noch einmal Nerd-News, geschrieben von Mo und präsentiert von Christina, und danach noch eine kleine Musik.
Die Bundesnetzagentur hat die Pflicht zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausgesetzt. Unter Berufung auf ein vorläufiges Urteil des Oberverwaltungsgerichts NRW hat die Regulierungsbehörde am Mittwoch angekündigt, sie werde derzeit keine Maßnahmen zur Durchsetzung ergreifen. Das Urteil galt nur für den Provider SpaceNet, der gegen das Gesetz geklagt hatte. Nach der Ankündigung der Behörde kündigten auch andere Provider an, bis zum Urteil im Hauptverfahren keine Verkehrsdaten zu erheben. Die Große Koalition hat sich auf eine Abschaffung der sogenannten Störerhaftung für WLAN-Betreiber verständigt. Wer ein offenes WLAN anbietet, kann damit nicht mehr abgemahnt werden, wenn über seinen Anschluss urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material verbreitet wird. Aber der Entwurf hat einen Haken. Stellt ein Rechtsinhaber künftig fest, dass über ein WLAN eine Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen wurde, kann er von dessen Betreiber verlangen, dass dieser den betreffenden Dienst sperrt, um eine Wiederholung der Rechtsverletzung auszuschließen. 50 Mbit pro Sekunde soll es bis Ende 2018 in jedem Haushalt geben. Das sagte Bundeskanzlerin Merkel zu. Auf einem Kongress der CDU-CSU-Fraktion zum digitalen Wandel räumte sie am Mittwoch ein, dass die Glasfaserverkabelung in Deutschland bisher – Zitat – vergleichsweise gering sei. Titel des Kongresses, Deutschland 4.0, das Potential der Digitalisierung nutzen. Bislang sind aber selbst die angestrebten 50 Mbit pro Sekunde erst für drei Viertel der deutschen Haushalte verfügbar.
Shell von Clam im Chaosradio 236, wo wir über Intrusion Detection und Incident Responding reden und beide am Ende angekommen sind. Und deswegen hätte ich noch eine kleine Insider-Frage, eine von mir, eine aus dem Publikum. Und zwar die von mir ist, wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit darüber geredet und ihr habt mir schön erklärt, wie man Angriffe von außen erkennt. Wie oft ist es ein Angreifer von innen oder gibt es das gar nicht?
Ja, da gibt es ja immer diese Zahlen. So 80 Prozent der Angriffe sind Insider. Aber das ist eben oft eine Definitionsfrage. Und da hat auch nie jemand irgendwie belastbares Datenmaterial geliefert.
Aber anekdotische Evidenz eurer bisherigen Karriere?
Ja, sag mal so, das kommt wieder drauf an, was man als Incident definiert. Also wenn man Mobbing hat, dann kann ich sagen, auch Mobbing ist ein Incident, dann sind es natürlich immer Innentäter. Aber so der klassische Spionage-Kram, der kommt heute von außen, weil das skaliert besser. Also ich kann ja jemanden in ein Unternehmen einschleusen und die Person ist dann aber in einem Unternehmen und die muss ja dann dort auch mal die Karriereleiter hochkletteln, um an die entsprechenden Daten ranzukommen, sich ein bisschen gewöhnen. Wenn ich Hacken über Internet mache, dann können meine vier oder fünf Hacker, dann können die zehn Unternehmen gleichzeitig angreifen und die skalieren viel besser. Wobei es natürlich auch sein kann, dass man so Hybridgeschichten hat, dass sich das natürlich kombiniert.
Und so ein frustrierter Angestellter, der mal eben das heißt, wenn es gar eine Firma platt machen will.
Man spricht da bei diesen Intätern auch immer gerne von Leuten, die halt abgeworben werden von anderen Unternehmen und dann erst mal eine eigene Datensenke betreiben und alle Informationen, die sie irgendwie mitnehmen können.
Ist nicht Whistleblower, sondern nehmen wir einmal ein fiktives Beispiel.
Du arbeitest für ein Versicherungsunternehmen und nimmst die Datenbank aller deiner Kunden mit und wechselst zu einem anderen Versicherungsunternehmen. Dann bist du als Mitarbeiter natürlich bei dem neuen Unternehmen daran interessiert, dass alle deine Kunden, die du bei dem Unternehmen A hattest, jetzt zum Unternehmen B kommen, wo du jetzt arbeitest.
Also eigentlich ja, aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass man auch in gewissen Nöte kommt, wenn man entdeckt, oh, dieses Ding, was ich verfolge, ist ein Whistleblower, der versucht, irgendwie schlimme Dinge aufzudecken.
Ich glaube typischerweise wird da jetzt nicht das Incident Response Team geholt, weil da ist es ja jetzt dann selten so, dass da großflächig irgendwelche Tools benutzt werden, die man nicht findet oder so. Also ich meine, falls uns mal jemand irgendwie, ich denke auch im Clubumfeld werden sich da viele Leute finden, falls mal irgendwer bei der NSA dazu kommt, da kleinere Tools zu installieren.
Oder nicht zu deinstallieren.
Das kann ja passieren, wenn man dann rüberwechselt und sich in die morale schaubere Ecke begibt und sinnvolle Dinge tut. Das wäre natürlich total bedauerlich, aber ich denke, dass das eher nicht so ist, dass man es typischerweise als Incident Responder als Case hat. Wenn man sagt, das soll irgendwie was mit Hacking zu tun haben oder mit Sicherheitslücken, dann kommt es in der Regel von außen. Wobei es natürlich auch in Netzen auch schon mal so erlebnisorientierte Personen gibt.
Feldef hat auf Twitter noch gefragt, inwiefern verhindert Hochmut des lokalen IT-Personals, dass so zeitnah wie möglich reagiert wird. Also ist euch das schon mal untergekommen, dass man sozusagen, man hätte euch schon vor einer Woche Bescheid sagen können, aber der Lokale hat man gesagt, nein, nein, das schaffe ich schon.
Das ist eigentlich normal. Also das ist ja auch der Punkt, warum wir da auch so am Anfang auch ein bisschen so Fragen angegangen sind wie Koordination. Da kann auf der Ebene gehen wirklich die meisten Sachen schief. Also erstens mal die Leute sind aufgeregt und das ist wirklich, das ist eben einfach ansteckend. Und dann trifft man falsche Entscheidungen. Auch routinierte Leute können sich davon anstecken lassen. Man muss dagegen echt ankämpfen. Und das ist dann eben einfach so nicht unbedingt, dass das Hochmut ist, sondern das ist einfach oft. Also ich würde da nie jemanden Vorwurf machen, weil er im Stress eine falsche Entscheidung trifft, weil das machen wir alle. Also so sind wir normal. Wenn jemand nicht in den Stress gerät, dann ist er routiniert. Und dann trifft er normalerweise keine falschen Entscheidungen mehr. Und da kann, es kann natürlich auch, also das Hauptproblem, glaube ich, ist immer, wenn man so diesen typischen, also was die Manager, glaube ich, so disconnect, zwischen Management und IT haben. Das heißt, da ist ein Admin bemerkt, oh, da geht was schief. Und er weiß aber oder befürchtet, dass wenn er da jemanden hinzuzieht, dass er dann derjenige ist, der eine auf den Deckel kriegt. Und so eine Situation, die ist natürlich, also die ist gelinde gesagt eine Katastrophe. Das darf eigentlich nicht passieren. Da sind das sozusagen die eine Ebene vor der anderen dann wirklich Angst hat oder eben in irgendeiner Form Repressalien befürchtet. Das kann auch unglaublich frustrierend sein, so ein Fall, wenn ein Admin sagt, ich wollte schon immer meinen Active Directory aufrollen, ich wollte schon immer patchen, man hat mir nie die Gelder, die Mittel gegeben. Jetzt fliegt mir alles um die Ohren. Jetzt würde ich am ersten nicht das Inzident behandeln, sondern ich würde gerne Leute umfausten. Und ja, das ist leider oft die Realität, wo viele Menschen arbeiten. Also IT ist ja nicht für viele Leute der Traumjob, das ist ganz schön stressig. Man hat Anforderungen von vielen Leuten, wo man weiß, dass sie manchmal nicht verstehen, was man wirklich leisten kann, was so machbar ist und was nicht. Das ist oft schon so eine Ecke, die ziemlich frustig ist. Und da hat man das Risiko, dass die daraus entstehenden Probleme, die vernünftige Behandlung des Inzidents verhindern, das ist leider Alltag. Das ist leider auch, glaube ich, in 50 Prozent der Fälle muss man mit so was rechnen.
Das ist ja ganz schön viel. Gibt es denn im Streben, sogar Handbücher auszugeben? Behandelt eure Atme jetzt besser? Dann passiert auch nicht so viel schlechtes Zeug?
Das wäre mal eine gute Idee. Also hier eine Idee von Mira ist natürlich auch so, was ja für einen Atmen oft frustrierend ist, wenn er was Neues lernt oder neue Sachen umsetzen soll, wo er merkt, hier, das würde mir was bringen. Also das Typische ist ein Atmen weiß, ich habe eine stundslangweilige Arbeit, die ich ständig machen muss, aber ich habe nicht die Zeit, sie zu automatisieren. Dann muss man dann eben auch mal gucken, okay, was hält meine Leute auf, wo sie wirklich sagen, wenn ich diese Arbeit mache, werde ich über die Jahre dümmer. Und dann genau dann eben den Leuten zuhören und zu sagen, okay, das irgendwie aus dem Weg räumen. Und klar, was natürlich dann auch die Realität ist, es gibt natürlich auch, also Geld liegt ja nicht auf der Straße, es gibt natürlich Unternehmen, wo einfach die Ressourcen nicht da sind. Das heißt, also da ist dann der Chef ist auch sozusagen Mitadmin, hat noch einen weiteren Kollegen. Und da ist dann natürlich einfach oft die Flexibilität nicht da. Da kann man dann irgendwie nichts weiter tun, als seinen Arbeitsablauf so gut wie möglich sozusagen zu organisieren. Aber sozusagen Frustration im IT-Bereich, das ist leider Alltag. Was natürlich auch immer ein wesentlicher Faktor ist, der da reinspielt, ist natürlich die Komplexität der IT-Umgebung. Also man möchte natürlich gerade bei knappen Ressourcen tendenziell dann eher einfache IT-Umgebungen haben, über die man dann auch mit dem kleinen Team einen Überblick behalten kann. Nicht, dass man sich irgendwie 5000 verschiedene Technologien ans Bein bindet, wo man jetzt gar nicht mehr irgendwie als Ganzes weiß noch, was da überhaupt steht im Netzwerk.
Ich will, weil wir jetzt bald schon wieder am Ende sind und mir schon hier in der Musikpause bedeutet wurde, wir müssten eigentlich noch sieben Tage alles verbrauchen zu haben. Ich will trotzdem noch mal fragen, die, also ich habe ja schon gesagt, im Vorfeld ist es gut, so ein Monitoring aufzubauen und da so, also, naja, nicht so viel, sondern so gezielt wie möglich Daten zu sammeln, die dabei helfen können, ein Incident, wenn es denn passiert, zu analysieren. Aber was ich auch sozusagen in den vergangenen zwei Stunden entnommen habe, ist, das Incident kommt. Egal wie gut du vorbereitest, das Incident kommt. Meine naive Annahme wäre sozusagen, okay, das ist möglicherweise schlimm, aber wenn ich ein Backup habe, ist alles nicht so schlimm. Muss man außer Backups noch irgendwas machen, um zu sagen, für den Fall eines Incidents gerüstet zu sein? Was braucht man da?
Also Backups helfen mir jetzt nicht, wenn mir Daten geklaut werden. Dann werden die vielleicht zweimal geklaut und in verschiedenen Versionen stellen. Aber natürlich macht es immer Sinn, eben wie schon vorhin erwähnt, einfach generisch in irgendeiner Form Monitoring und irgendwie so Collection-Infrastruktur, sag ich mal, dass ich irgendwie auf meinen Hosts Informationen bekomme, dass ich irgendeine Möglichkeit habe, sei es jetzt irgendwie Tools, sei es irgendwie von mir aus auch selbst gebaute PowerShell-Skripte, aber dass ich irgendwie meinetwegen Dateien von Hosts irgendwie einsammeln kann über so einen Audit-Account, dass ich in irgendeiner Form schnelle Zugriffsmöglichkeiten auf einzelne Systeme habe, um eben dann auch Alarmmeldungen zu verifizieren oder zu falsifizieren, die ich dann eben in meinem Sieben- oder in meinem anderen Monitoring irgendwie habe. Das macht natürlich auch im Incident-Fall dann einfach ganz viel Arbeit aus. Wenn man das schon hat, das ist dann schon super. Ja, und das andere ist halt auch, irgendwelche Fallstricke vermeiden. Also die meisten Angreifer sind darauf getrimmt, zu wissen, dass es schwierig ist, bestimmte Systeme auszutauschen. Das heißt, die verbreiten sich im Netz, sie machen jetzt nicht unbedingt Sachen, die super schwer zu erkennen sind, sondern verräsen sich einfach rein und verstecken sich und wissen einfach, okay, die wenigsten Organisationen können einfach mal ihr Netz so lange abschalten, bis man das eben alles behoben hat und bis man es dann wieder anfährt. Das heißt, man kann sich eben wirklich überlegen, okay, wie kann ich Systeme ersetzen, wenn man sagt, ich kann sie dann anders nicht mehr retten. Also der Angreifer hat mir sozusagen, wie man sagt, würde eben zu viele Changes gemacht, also dass ich die vernünftig zurückrollen kann. Wie kann ich diese Systeme ersetzen? Und halt, das ist wie im normalen Betrieb, wenn ich eine Infrastruktur habe, wo ich genau weiß, wenn ich hier eine kleine Änderung mache und ein System ersetze, dann kommt ein Bergarbeit oder Störung auf mich zu. Das ist dann genau die Sache, die mich bei einem Incident, wenn man es so deutlich sagen will, wirklich in den Hintern beißt. Weil dann habe ich den Angreifer auf einem System und ich kriege ihn nicht deswegen runter, weil ich nicht verstehe, was er macht, sondern weil ich, wenn ich das System austausche, einen Ausfall habe. Und genau diese Sollbruchstellen, da sind manche Angreifer relativ gut, sie zu finden. Da steht natürlich auch die Vermutung nahe, weil sie selber ehemalige Admins sind. Was vielleicht dann auch nicht so ganz uninteressant ist, ist, gerade wenn man eben irgendwie so Windows-basierte Infrastruktur hat, dass man da vielleicht mal so ein bisschen Ticket-Reset, also ein Kerberos Ticket-Ranting, Ticket-Account-Reset übt. Also so Reset der Authentifizierungs-Infrastruktur in so einer Windows-Domäne, wie man das sinnvoll tut.
Nutzer-Namen und Kenwörter für alle im Grunde genommen in der Infrastruktur einmal zurückzusetzen und einen Passwortwechsel durchzuführen, damit alte Nutzer-Credentials, mit denen man sich auf Systemen authentifizieren konnte, halt nicht mehr gültig sind, weil man diese als kompromittiert ansehen muss, da die dem Angreifer im Zweifelsfall in die Hände gefallen sind.
Ja, und eben es gibt noch so eine Art von Angriff, dass es genau auszuführen geht, vielleicht ein bisschen weit noch für die Zeit, die wir noch haben, aber eben so ein Golden-Ticket-Angriff, da kann man im Prinzip ohne aktiv auf dem Domain-Controller, zum Beispiel in einer Windows-Domain, irgendwie Spuren zu hinterlassen, sich ein Credential-Ticket, also in irgendeiner Form ein Kerberos-Ticket-Factory, ein Login ziehen, der irgendwie zehn Jahre gültig ist. Und den kann ich dann noch später benutzen, wenn ich einmal rausgeworfen wurde, um danach, wenn ich wieder irgendwo einen Host aufmachen konnte, mich direkt als privilegierter User wieder im System zu bewegen.
Und ich sehe aber auch gar nicht, dass es diesen User gibt.
Nee, den sieht man normalerweise nicht. Das ist eben ein technischer User, der lebt auf den Domain-Controllern. Und das ist halt auch so ein Account, den fasst man normalerweise einfach nicht an. Also es gibt keinerlei Grund, normalerweise, wenn man irgendwelche Microsoft-Dokumentationen liest, diesen User überhaupt anzufassen. Da können auch lustige Dinge passieren, wenn man das vorher nicht mal gemacht hat, wenn man den dann resetet. Und ja genau, den muss man eben im Fall, wenn man eben einen Goldenticketangriff vermutet oder vielleicht sinnvollerweise im Rahmen einer regelmäßigen Übung, dann zweimal resetten, um eben so ein Goldenticket dann zu invalidaten.
Meine Güte, je länger wir drüber reden, desto mehr habe ich den Eindruck, und das geht mir auch beim Chaos-Radio so, ich möchte mit der ganzen Sache eigentlich nichts zu tun haben. Bewarb bitte die Ruhe.
Genau.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob mir das jetzt noch gelingt, weil was wir im Prinzip gesagt haben, es geht schief. Also es geht schief und es wird schlimm. Ja, deswegen ist es wichtig, in solchen Situationen einfach Ruhe zu bewahren.
Vielleicht in Entscheidungen, die man treffen möchte, nochmal zu überdenken und auch sich eine Strategie zu überlegen, wie man vorgehen möchte und nicht wie man im Regelfall handeln würde, sondern eigentlich davon umgekehrt zu handeln, um auch den Angreifer entsprechend den Angreifern haphaft zu werden.
Oder einfach auch mal warten, bis man gewisse Dinge durchführt, um entsprechend den Angreifer weiter beobachten zu können.
Also da ist sich ruhig verhalten, gucken, gucken, gucken und weiter gucken sehr wichtig.
Weil was? Damit man sieht, wie der Angreifer weiter vorgeht. Ach so, damit man dann sehen kann, wie er rein kann. Du willst dir ja auch einen Plan darüber machen, wie seine Strategie ist, vorzugehen. Und da möchtest du ihn natürlich packen und versuchen, die Strategie auszuhebeln. Und je mehr Informationen du über einen Angreifer hast, desto besser kannst du entsprechend gegen ihn vorgehen.
Was Zebras noch meinte, ist dann auch, wenn man eben dann einmal irgendwie weiß, ok, da springt jetzt irgendwo in diesem und diesem Netz ein Angreifer rum. Und ich habe so eine grobe Ahnung, auf welchen System, dass man dann auch hingeht und schaut, ok, was für Tools benutzt denn der Angreifer, wo kommuniziert er denn hin, eben wie ihr auch vorhin schon erwähnt, welche C2 Server benutzt er denn so, um da dann einfach so Signaturen und Footprint für den Angreifer zu bauen. Und das dann natürlich auch entsprechend auszurollen, im natürlich besten Fall im ganzen Netz, um dann eben alle Ecken zu finden, wo vielleicht der Angreifer sich nochmal bewegt hat, wo er vielleicht irgendwo eine Web-Share nochmal in irgendeine andere DMZ gelegt hat und so Dinge. Das will man dann schon systematisch machen und nicht direkt hoch irgendein komisches Tool, was vielleicht böse ist und jetzt nuke ich den Rechner und dann weiß ich aber immer noch nicht, ob vielleicht das nur ein Tool von sechs waren.
Also nicht rausschwerfen, sondern ein bisschen beobachten, um zu sehen, wo er überall hingeht und dann dort die Schlösser auszutauschen.
Und auch, um einfach eine sehr schön erklärte Set an Signaturen und an Eigenschaften, die der Angreifer typischerweise so mit sich bringt. Das kann alles Mögliche sein. Einfach Malversignaturen, komische Verhaltensweisen, Vorlieben für bestimmte Verzeichnisse, wo irgendwie Zeug hingelegt wird, die man sich dann natürlich anschauen will. Oder auch einfach irgendwelche User-Accounts, die der Angreifer anlegt, wenn er halt typischerweise irgendwie Rute auf irgendeinem System ist und sich da noch einen User anlegt.
Okay, das hat es nicht unbedingt besser gemacht, wenn man sozusagen eine der Strategien ist, wir lassen den Anbrecher einfach noch ein bisschen in unserer Wohnung. Wir sind fast am Ende der Sendung angekommen. Sebas, Mira, Rolper Tu und Dinos, vielen Dank schon mal an dieser Stelle. Ich würde aber noch ein paar, also so zwei, drei Minuten hätten wir noch, gibt es noch eine Sache, die wir jetzt nicht geschafft haben und die wir jetzt auch nicht ganz in Rollen können, aber die ihr unbedingt noch sagen wollt?
Es gibt, glaube ich, einen ziemlich banalen Trick, den man immer haben sollte. Man hat ja dann immer irgendwo bei einem Betroffenen so eine Betriebsmannschaft, die irgendwie den Überblick hat. Und die ist natürlich bei so einem Incident, wie es so schön heißt, unverzichtbar, weil die weiß, wie der Laden funktioniert. Und eine der ersten Sachen, die man tun kann, ist dann sofort diese Leute entlasten. Also zu gucken, dass die dann nicht mehr ihre Alltagsaufgaben machen, sondern dass man da jemand findet, damit die sich wirklich voll und ganz dem Sicherheitsvorfall widmen können. Denn in ihrem Kopf sind dann oft die wichtigsten und die besten Informationen. Also nimm mal an, du hast einen Admin, der muss für Außendienstler die Telefone einrichten. Dann kann man sagen, okay, da haben wir wahrscheinlich gute Chancen, jemanden zu finden, der ihn da entlasten kann, damit er einfach sagen kann, hey, mein Laden funktioniert so und so. Und da und da brauche ich Unterstützung, da und da brauche ich keine. Also das ist extrem hilfreich. Also dem heimischen IT-Personal ein artgerechtes und schöne Umgebung bieten. Also wenn die IT nicht glücklich ist, dann ist das nicht gut.
Das macht mir alles, also weil ich wieder denke so, hey, wenn meine Firma was explodiert, dann stelle ich natürlich die Leute frei, die am ehesten dabei helfen können. Aber es scheint nicht Standard zu sein, wenn wir das jetzt extra nochmal ansagen.
Es ist tatsächlich nicht Standard.
Und das ist eigentlich doch das Schlimme.
Und meine Empfehlung wäre da auch zu sagen, an das Management von einem Unternehmen, auf die Betriebsmannschaft hören. Auf die Leute, die zum Incident Response kommen und auf die Betriebsmannschaft hören.
Die Entscheidungen, die dort gefällt worden sind, sind umzusetzen und nicht mehr zu diskutieren.
Ende aus.
Warte mal, das Management soll auf die Leute hören, die die eigentliche Arbeit machen? Das wäre glaube ich zum ersten Mal. Das geht ja nur wirklich nicht.
Das rutscht in meinen Radikalismus ab. Man kann nicht überlegen, ob man die Incident Responder alle 200 Tage im Unternehmen haben möchte oder ob man das Ganze einfach mal lösen möchte.
Diese völlig weltfremden Technologien und Strategien. Wir müssen schnell die Sendung beenden. Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart. Ich bin auch aufgetragen worden, eine Sache auszurichten, nämlich der Chaos Computer Club macht nicht nur das Chaos-Radio, sondern wird auch beim G20-Gipfel in Hamburg dabei sein. Fast. Es wird dort zwei Aktionen geben zum G20-Gipfel, nämlich vom FCMC und There Is No Time. FCMC ist ein freies Medienzentrum im Stadion des FC St. Pauli, für das sich die Journalisten auch akkreditieren können. Und der CCC unterstützt dort mit Video- und Netztechnik und helfenden Händen, sind also auch Leute vor Ort. Und There Is No Time will ebenfalls über den G20 berichten. Auch hier gibt es Unterstützung aus dem Chaos Computer Club. Und das Ganze geht los am Dienstag, den 11. Juli um 18 Uhr. FCMCTV oder There Is No time.net sind die Adressen, wo ihr das sehen könnt. Also das erstellte G20-Material mit technischer Unterstützung des CCC. Viel Spaß dabei. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich kann nur noch eine Sache an dieser Stelle sagen, die möglicherweise schon gesagt worden ist. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.